well i mean listen elon musk just sold
his last house in california for thirty
seven point six million dollars
yeah the san francisco the san francisco
it's like it's like
50 acres it's 50 acres it's 16 000
square feet it's a beautiful place yet
it's the last property here to sell
people are leaving
can you buy that and make it a boutique
hotel that's a huge property people
are leaving it's that simple that's
exactly right
not because of culture not because of
industries not because of any of that we
got to tell him
he's screaming and hollering not because
of any of that
they're leaving because of bad policies
very simple
when my kids ask me a question they say
hey daddy who are we voting for
what do you think about this president
what do you think about that president
you know somebody in school you know
they're going to school and
somebody in school told me that trump is
for rich people and bidens for poor
people who should we be
uh for right he's explained he's asking
this question i'm having these types of
conversation with my kids
it's interesting because you see the
teacher saying certain things and these
kids are coming home and they're sharing
it with you right
i said look kids it's not never the
individual forget about the individual i
don't look at the individual
i don't care if the individual does
whatever they want to do i don't you
don't care if they drink alcohol that's
not my business daddy that's their
business if they want to drink
but if you produce policies that produce
negative results
that's when i become concerned i said
it's a policy war
it's nothing more than policies so when
people ask which president do you like
they'll say
i disagree with biden's policies
six-year-old dylan a seven-year-old
dylan says i don't agree with his policy
what percentage of america do you
actually think thinks that way
no man what are you talking about what
percentage
less than twenty percent yeah i would
say way less yeah i know
the only reason i said one five percent
is because one in five makes six figures
in america today
so i i would say 20 i think it's a 20
number
who's actually sitting there thinking
about it who's actually sitting there
saying here's what we have to be
thinking about so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye